alle wachsam haben schon gesehen aber
okay hier ist ein blog das könnten offen
sein aber es ist ein dispenser wenn wir
jetzt dieses peter rein schauen sehen
wir dass da ein
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich bin heute am pc
vom max deswegen auch der kahlkopf das
kind und ich möchte euch halte heute
genau ich möchte euch heute einen
jumpsuit vorstellen dafür befinden wir
uns in einer runde mit der endmärkte
oder es aussprechen möchte und wir
laufen erst mal das jump'n'run durch und
dann am ende guck mir wo sie dass sie
gut befindet ich finde das ist ein
ziemliches opc gut weil das alte muss im
dispenser bekommt man nicht so gut wie
nie hat ein job liegt meiner meinung
nach ziemlich op
okay leute wir finnischen jetzt
springens deathmatch und dann zeige ich
euch das versteck und zwar wie gesagt
die maps und wir gehen mal hier in
diesen großen turm deiner mittelrhein
glaubt theoretisch kann man auch über
diese treppe da rein hier einfach zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack ja das
sollte passen hier leute sind das die
zweitklässler alles klar leute wir
müssen aber noch eine ebene weiter höher
und zwar auf die oberste ebene so okay
so könnte sich das allerdings befinden
alle wachsamer schon gesehen aber okay
hier ist ein blog das könnte offen sein
aber es ist ein dispenser wenn wie jetzt
in diesen dispenser rein schauen sehen
wir dass da ein eisen schwert drin ist
einfach clinton eisenstädter drin
versteckt man kann locker isin ist kein
job dran oder so was ist nicht so tricky
wie auch in europa zwei da war der power
1 bogen da unten so man kann einfach
direkt da hoch laufen quasi und das
eigentlich spannende secret aber erst
noch allgemein vorweg zu schicken es
gibt leute die behaupten dass quasi das
veröffentlichen von secret sind
spielspaß zerstören würde
das halte ich persönlich für bullshit
ich habe auch immer das endoskop a2
sigrid für den power 1 bogen und ein
video gemacht dass wieder hat im mega
viele klicks auf bekomme 220.000 oder so
und trotzdem wenn ich jetzt heute noch
in europa zwei und spiele dann ist es
mir gesagt man nie passiert dass direkt
am anfang einer darunter renten diesen
bogen holt was halt alle geschrieben
haben sollte motor des zerstörten
spielspaß jetzt kennt jeder das secret
aber obwohl das video so viele klicks
hat benutzen gar nicht so viel dass sie
gut deswegen mache ich mir auch bei dem
secret hier keine sorgen ein paar werden
es kennen und es ist witzig und ich mein
selbst ins jeder kennt ist es auch nicht
schlimm da geht's halt darum wer zuerst
da hoch gerannt ist dann halt an eisen
schwert und bis dahin ist es noch ein
kleiner tipp was auch ganz cool ich so
für die community übrigens dass hier
gehen wir von einem zuschauer empfohlen
von finn ich halt ethno dem auftritt
meinte bei der website gibt's in secret
dankeschön an dich finden das ist nicht
ganz cool so das ticket war dann kann
man wenn man jetzt zum beispiel zwei
sand wie ich die dafür verwenden dass
man sich ein fn es macht aber sowas oder
für andere keine ahnung fucking
keuschheitsgürtel ich weiß es nicht auf
jeden fall könnte reisen anders
verwenden und ihr habt wenn ich schnell
genug seid garantiert in jeder runde
eisens wert auf ästhetik und das ist
ziemlich ziemlich okay
auf jeden fall dank fürs zuschauen heute
wenn sonst irgendwelche von euch
irgendwelche secret scannen von denen er
denkt dass es cool wenn es andere leute
vielleicht auch wissen dann könnte die
gerne per twitter youtube
eher waren wir schicken ihr kriegt ja
natürlich kredite für einem video und ja
das was so alles klar [ __ ] you das war
es von diesem video von mir macht's gut
und bis zum nächsten